alors nous en avons tous rêvé
transformer le plomb en or
la transmutation donc cette recette
cette recette d'alchimiste permettait
grâce à la température de transformer
des métaux dits impurs en or alors
aujourd'hui les scientifiques physiciens
chimistes évidemment ne savent pas
recréer cette transmutation
par contre nous avons réussi à dompter
la pression et grâce à la pression nous
allons pouvoir faire mieux
nous allons pouvoir transformer du
beurre de cacahuètes en diamants alors
je vous la corde le diamant ne ressort
pas de l'expérience aussi bien taillée
néanmoins la pression a réussi à
monopoliser les atomes de carbone qui
sont présents dans le beurre de
cacahuète et informer du diamant avant
d'aller plus loin dans cette aventure de
la transformation
regardons un petit peu ce qu'est la
pression donc la pression c'est une
force qui est appliqué à une surface
donc le poids de mon corps par
l'intermédiaire de mes pieds 1 mon petit
47 fillette applique une pression sur le
sol de même les 30 ou 40 km d'atmosphère
que nous avons au dessus de nos têtes
applique sur nous tous une pression donc
la pression dit atmosphérique
vous le savez cette pression vaut
environ un bar soit à peu près une
atmosphère c'est aussi équivalent à 100
milles pascal le pascal étant l'unité du
système international
alors dans votre vie de tous les jours
vous rencontrez des pressions assez
modeste quand vous gonfler vos pneus de
vélos de voiture la cocotte minute qui
monte à peu près à 1,5 barre les gens
qui font de la plongée sous-marine
savent que quand on s'enfonce dans l'eau
la pression ressentie augmente de 1 bar
tous les dix mètres
alors pour faire de diamants qu'elle ait
la pression dont on a besoin
alors historiquement ce n'est que quand
les géologues ont compris que le diamant
venait des profondeurs de la terre et
qu'il n'était constitué que de carbone
que la la course à la synthèse du
diamant a commencé le diamant à des
telles propriétés que c'est un enjeu
industriel très important alors depuis
le début au plus haut depuis la fin du
19e siècle
toutes les tentatives de synthèse du
diamant ont échoué y compris celles de
deux prix
bale 1 de physique et de chimie au début
des années 50
tracy hall a inventé une machine qui
permettait à la fois de mettre du
graphite sous pression et de le chauffer
à très haute température
c'est quelque chose qu'on ne savait pas
faire jusqu'à jusqu'à lors donc il a il
a pris du graffiti la montée ce
graphique à 2000 degrés et sous 3 giga
pascal donc un giga pascal ça représente
enfin 3 giga pascal ça représente
environ 30 mille fois la pression
atmosphérique
alors ici le la pression à transformer
de manière très profonde le graphite
vous avez ce matériau qui est noir
d'aspe un peu métallique et on en a on
en a fait un art un matériau
parfaitement transparent le graphite
aussi c'est un des minéraux les plumes
ou qu'on connaisse et ça a été
transformé en le plus dur de tous c'est
un conducteur électrique certes pas très
bon mais on l'a transformée dans un
parfait parfait isolants électriques et
beaucoup d'autres propriétés comme ça
ont été modifiés
2 par la pression alors pourquoi dans le
graphite les atomes de carbone sont
arrangés en feuillets les atomes au sein
d'un même feuillets sont liés entre eux
par des liaisons très forte très solide
par contre les liaisons chimiques
interfel y est elles sont très faibles
donc les feuillets vont pouvoir glisser
les uns sur les autres
de cette manière la pointe de crayon va
laisser une trace sur le papier on va
aussi utiliser le graphite comme
lubrifiant par contre dans le diamant
tous les atomes de carbone sont liés
entre eux par ses liaisons très forte
donc la pression a obligé les à thomas
serait à ranger dans une structure plus
compacte et plus rigides alors
l'utilisation du beurre de cacahuète
pouvait paraître intéressante parce que
ça allie l'utile à l'agréable
mais la réaction produit de l'hydrogène
qui a un peu tendance à exploser
donc c'est pour ça que le scientifique
se sont rabattus sur le graphique
alors qu'est-ce que quels sont les types
de machines que l'on utilise pour faire
ce type d'expérience est ce qu'on peut
faire de la synthèse de diamant dans
notre cocotte minute
alors on utilise pour dépression qui
vont jusqu'à 30 giga pascal donc trois
cent mille fois la pression
atmosphérique
on utilise des presses hydrauliques ici
derrière moi vous avez un exemple de
presse hydraulique qui est installé dans
une université à byron en allemagne donc
une presse déjà de belle taille vous
voyez c'est ce type de presse donc
permet aller jusqu'à des pressions de
300 mille fois la pression atmosphérique
et pour essayer de se rendre compte un
petit peu de ce que représentent ces
pressions énormes
je vous ai mis une coupe de la terre à
côté pour voir une pour avoir une
correspondance pression profondeur dans
la terre donc et 3 giga pascal de nos
premières synthèses de diamants ont été
réalisés donc 20 correspondent à peu
près à 100 km de profondeur
les 30 giga pascal de nos grosses presse
d'aujourd'hui
elles correspondent à environ 1000 km de
profondeur donc c'est déjà considérable
pouvoir réaliser des expériences dans
des conditions équivalentes à celles de
1000 km de profondeur
le problème c'est que pour explorer la
terre et des autres planètes
il faut pouvoir aller plus loin en
pression est la même les meilleurs à 6
ans leurs limites
donc rien ne sert de construire des
presses de plus en plus grosse ça ne
marchera pas par contre on peut se
rappeler notre petite équation
mathématique de tout à l'heure la
pression c'est une force / une surface
donc si je dis minima surface j'augmente
ma pression je vais donc utiliser je
vais donc construire des presses
beaucoup plus petit
et au lieu d'utiliser de l'acier qui est
trop mou vous avez certainement deviné
je vais utiliser du diamant nous allons
donc étudier la matière sous des
pressions extrêmes dans des presses fait
de diamant alors voici un schéma de ce
type de presse c'est ce qu'on appelle
une cellule enclume de diamant donc le
principe est assez simple la mise en
place mise en oeuvre est un peu plus
compliqué donc on prend de diamants que
l'on met en opposition et au bout de ces
diamants on va tailler une petite
tablette plate qu'on va appeler la
culasse cette classe elle fait entre 10
et 7 100 microns de diamètre
pour vous donner une idée un cheveu fait
entre 50 et 100 microns de diamètre en
moyenne donc c'est tout petit et plus je
peux monter en pression plus je vais
prendre une surface petit
donc entre ces deux diamants je vais
placer mes échantillons et
éventuellement un joint au tour pour que
tout reste en place et ensuite en
appliquant une force sur les diamants
je vais mettre mes échantillons sous
pression je peux aussi mettre du gaz à
côte afin dans cet espace expérimental
où se trouvent mes échantillons de pas
de façon à ce que les diamants appuyé
sur le gaz et le conte presse et le gaz
va transférer la pression aux
échantillons ça évite d'appuyer
directement et de casser les
échantillons alors je vais aussi
exploiter une propriété extraordinaire
du diamant qui est sa grande
transparence
donc je vais pouvoir alors que
l'échantillon est sous haute pression
éventuellement sous une température
regarder en direct les transformations
qu'il subit soit à travers un microscope
optique classique soit en utilisant
d'autres types de lumière des rayons x
ou les infrarouges ce petit instrument
comme vous voyez en haut à droite donc
ce modèle fait 5 cm de diamètre donc
pourrait tenir dans ma main a
révolutionné la physique de haute
pression on peut avec ses instruments
réalisés dépression qui sont supérieures
à celles qui règnent au centre de la
terre c'est à dire plus de 3,6 millions
de fois la pression atmosphérique donc
des pressions considérables
alors pour vous donner un exemple de
recherche qui sont faits avec ses
instruments
à tout seigneur tout honneur je vais
commencer par l'hydrogène donc
l'hydrogène c'est l'élément le plus
abondant de l'univers
c'est aussi le plus simple de tous il
est composé d'un électron et d'un proton
donc ça en fait un élément
particulièrement intéressant pour les
théoriciens cet hydrogène
c'est le diamant de demain le grand
oeuvre des arches des alchimistes
d'aujourd'hui c'est de réaliser un métal
à partir de ce titre aux gènes on a
prédit depuis les années 30 que sous
très haute pression
l'hydrogène doit se transformer en métal
et pas n'importe quel métal mais un
métal supraconducteurs à température
ambiante supraconducteurs ça veut dire
que si vous faites passer de
l'électricité dans ce métal
vous n'avez aucune perte d'électricité
le métal n'a aucune résistance
électrique
aujourd'hui on connaît des
supraconducteurs mais ils ne le sont
qu'à des températures d'environ moins
° ça en limite dont beaucoup les
applications et on ne peut les utiliser
que dans des domaines très spécifiques
donc imaginez un petit peu avoir un
morceau de métal supraconducteurs à
température ambiante
ce serait absolument révolutionnaire là
on sait depuis plusieurs années que
l'hydrogène devient effectivement solide
environ 100 giga pascal donc un million
de fois la pression atmosphérique
malheureusement c'est un c'est ce qu'on
appelle un semis métal c'est à dire
c'est un assez mauvais conducteur
d'électricité
donc on a poussé un peu plus loin
jusqu'à 400 giga pascal et l'a toujours
pas de supraconductivité
on sait tourner alors vers le liquide
l'hydrogène liquide qui lui aussi a été
prédit supraconducteurs mais aussi être
un super fluide un super fluide c'est un
fluide qui n'a aucune viscosité vous
versez de l'hydrogène liquide dans un
bol il en ressort aussitôt
si vous pouviez nager dans une piscine
d'hydrogène liquide vous ne ressentirez
absolument aucune résistance
alors là aussi on a fait des expériences
jusqu'à 300 genia pascal là non plus
aucun état exotiques de la matière alors
faut-il pousser plus fort faut-il aller
plus loin en pression alors oui il le
faut parce que si l'on veut comprendre
le fonctionnement des planètes géantes
comme jupiter
il faut qu'on puisse créer en
laboratoire des pressions beaucoup plus
grande donc jupiter est principalement
composée d'hydrogène avec un peu
d'hélium
c'est un monstre de 70 mille kilomètres
de rayon donc plus de 10 fois le rayon
terrestre qui fait environ 6000 400km au
sommet de cette couche rose fuchsia que
vous voyez la pression est déjà de
l'ordre de 100 giga pascal donc un
million de fois la pression
atmosphérique au centre de jupiter on
estime la pression à plus de 7000 giga
pascal donc là c'est absolument
inimaginable
alors évidemment ces pressions ne sont
pas accessibles aux diamants il faut
passer un autre instrument est donc là
on va construire des facilité d
installation massive de laser comme
celle qui a le projet mega joule qui se
trouve près de bordeaux alors si vous
voyez une image de
enfin des images d'une installation
américaine et pour vous nous donner une
idée de la taille
ce bâtiment couvre environ trois
terrains de football et dans sa plus
haute hauteur il fait une dizaine
d'étagés à droite vous voyez de
l'extérieur la chambre expérimental dans
laquelle va se trouver l'échantillon les
amateurs de star trek reconnaîtront
peut-être une scène un lieu de tournage
du film star trek into darkness
alors cette chambre expérimental vous
voyez elle est sur la droite du schéma
du bâtiment c'est ce petit objet un peu
sphérique rouge que vous devinez et plus
à gauche
vous voyez tous ces tubes donc tous ses
tubes ce sont des lasers je ne parle pas
de laser de caumont à pour faire des
présentations
je vous parle de trucs un peu sérieux
ici dans ce bâtiment il ya environ 200
laser c200 laser vont tirer en même
temps avec une synchronisation parfaite
des faisceaux qui vont converger sur
cette petite capsule que vous voyez en
haut à gauche de l'image qui ne fait que
quelques millimètres de longueur
donc tous ses fils vont converger
exactement au même moment dans cette
capsule
ils vont donc instantanément déposer une
quantité d'énergie tels que ça va créer
une onde de choc et cette onde de choc
va elle même créé des hautes pressions
qui vont qui peuvent dépasser les
pressions qui règne à l'intérieur de
jupiter ces techniques peuvent aussi
augmenter faire élever la température à
des températures à des valeurs
complètement hallucinante alors une
équipe internationale l'été dernier
avait effectué des expériences sur
l'hydrogène jusqu'à 3 terrain pascal
pour l'instant les résultats ne sont pas
publiés donc le suspense demeure mais il
est certain que nous allons découvrir
des états exotiques de la matière
d'autres expériences ont été faites dans
ce type d'installation sur le diamant
justement on a essayé de regarder
jusqu'où le diamant pouvait être stable
ce diamant d'une stabilité
extraordinaire puisqu'il reste diamant
jusqu'à 1 tera pascal donc jusqu'à 10
millions de fois la pression
atmosphérique
au-delà de cette pression comment on
atteint vraiment des seuils extrême des
pressions extrêmes pour les expériences
les avis divergent sur ce qui se passe
au delà de ce terrain pascal on a fait
aussi un autre type d'expérience on a
essayé de faire fondre le diamant l'or
le diamant qui est un matériau très
rigide ne font pas facilement et donc
des expériences ont été faites dans
cette même installation entre 1 et 2,5
terra pascal et pour faire fondre le
diamant il a fallu monter la température
jusqu'à cinquante mille degrés alors à
50 mille degrés le diamant fonds et
devient liquide et là surprise
l'isolant électrique devient un
conducteur donc le liquide diamant est
un métal l'autre petite surprise c'est
que ce liquide est plus dense que son
solide
donc si je pouvais pour faire refroidir
un bain de diamant j'aurai des cristaux
de diamants qui flotterait en surface
donc ceci me fait dire que marvin ross
en 1980 dans cet article publié nature
avait peut-être raison
les platines les plupart dans les
planètes uranus neptune qui sont riches
en méthane ch4 on peut être deux océans
de méthane sur laquelle flottent des
icebergs de diamants alors vous l'avez
compris la pression change profondément
les propriétés des matériaux les
liaisons chimiques sont perturbées les
électrons qui gravitent autour de leurs
noyaux sont complètement chamboulé et de
là va naître toute une nouvelle physique
tout une nouvelle chimie alors j'aurais
pu vous parler de beaucoup d'autres
choses des multiples faces de la glace
de l'oxygène qui fait des très beaux
cristaux rouges sang sous haute pression
du xénon que vos professeur de chimie
vous ont vendu comme étant un gaz inerte
mettait l'eau sous pression il réagit
avec n'importe quoi j'aurais pu vous
parler du silicium noir qui demain qui
fera peut-être nos cellules
photovoltaïques donc la pression les
études sous haute pression font partie
de cet ensemble qu'on appelle donc les
études sous conditions extrêmes elles
sont en train de forger c'est qu'ils
seront demain peut-être les matériaux
que nous utiliserons dans notre
technologie
donc si on arrive à comprendre les
mécanismes qui fait que c'est mais c'est
ces matériaux acquiert des propriétés
étrange à très haute pression on pourra
peut-être trouvé des processus
industriels pour synthétiser des
matériaux qui auront ces mêmes
propriétés par exemple la
supraconductivité à haute température
alors donc aujourd'hui dans les
laboratoires de recherche se dessine
peut-être les matériaux que nous
utiliserons non pas demain dans notre
technologie mais après demain
et en ces périodes de disette où les
crédits de la recherche font d'année en
année nous chercheurs passionnés nous
sommes prêts à faire notre effort mais
nous ne travaillerons pas pour des
cacahuètes
merci